economía en france 24 me acompaña en el
estudio daniel hablando con daniela
buena noche bienvenida las exportaciones
en américa latina' habrían caído un 13%
en el año 2020 hola buenas noches al
menos eso es lo que dice un informe de
la comisión económica para américa
latina y el caribe porque las cifras
oficiales todavía tienen corte a octubre
la nueva proyección es más optimista que
la anterior porque en agosto se pensaba
que las ventas externas de los países
latinoamericanos iban a caer un 23%
ahora 13 por ciento lo que sí se sabe es
que la mayor caída de las exportaciones
se no todos los países de la misma
región latinoamericana con poco más del
24 por ciento le siguen las ventas a
eeuu y a la unión europea que bajaron 14
y 13 por ciento respectivamente y el
único crecimiento fue para china que
durante la pandemia ha demandado más
productos agrícolas y minerales de esta
zona en general esta es la peor caída de
las exportaciones regionales desde la
gran recesión que fue la crisis de la
década de
o mejor la del 2008 así es daniela pero
también la llegada de joe biden ya cursó
el primer malestar de que se trata de
una de las primeras órdenes ejecutivas
que firmó el nuevo presidente de eeuu
fue la suspensión del polémico oleoducto
keystone ex el que se ha convertido por
varios años en símbolo de la lucha
contra el cambio climático este es un
oleoducto de casi 2000 kilómetros que
transportará hacia eeuu grandes
cantidades de petróleo producido en
alberta canadá este es un estado que
contiene una de las mayores reservas
petroleras del mundo pero grupos
indígenas se han opuesto por varios años
y en 2015 su construcción fue rechazada
por barack obama en 2017 fue desaprobada
por donald trump y ahora vuelve a ser
suspendida por byd en lo que no dejó muy
contento al gobierno canadiense
obviamente la decisión sobre quiste
excel es muy difícil para los
trabajadores de alberta y saskatchewan
que han tenido muchos golpes difíciles
en los últimos años
spears agua
a express expresar mi preocupación sobre
los empleos y medios de vida en canadá
particularmente en el occidente en mi
conversación con el presidente de
inversión
daniela amazon comenzará a aplicar la
llamada 'tasa google' si mire el 16 de
enero entró en vigencia un impuesto
sobre determinados servicios digitales
en español por el momento amazon está
absorbiendo ese costo según agencias y
medios locales pero a partir de abril
comenzará a cargarles este gravamen a
las empresas que utilizan su plataforma
entre ellas más de nueve mil pequeñas y
medianas países de todo el mundo están
examinando las formas de gravar con más
fuerza a las empresas tecnológicas
globales sobre sus ingresos en europa
hay todo un debate sobre la denominada
tasa google un impuesto que gravará a
las grandes tecnológicas con un 3 por
ciento de sus ingresos obtenidos por los
servicios digitales que presten en los
diferentes países pero hay naciones como
francia y españa que han decidido
comenzar los a aplicar unilateralmente
danielle y como le parece que hasta los
falsificadores de billetes están en
cuarentena como le parece raúl
si es muy bueno mira hay un reporte del
banco central europeo que dice que el
número de billetes falsos en la zona
euro en 2020 cayó a su nivel más bajo
desde que existe esta moneda y todo
gracias a que a la pandemia algo bueno
tenía que salir en total se retiraron de
circulación unos 460.000 billetes falsos
esto supone una disminución de casi el
18 por ciento comparado con 2019 los más
falsificados siguen siendo los de 20 y
50 euros y su circulación es
relativamente baja porque en total hay
más de 25 mil millones de billetes de
euros en circulación esto quiere decir
que el año pasado se detectaron 17
ejemplares falsos por cada millón
auténticos danielle indicadores hubo
cierre mixto en la bolsa de nueva york
pero el único índice que subió el nasdaq
que es el que aglutina las tecnológicas
volvió a marcar un récord en europa del
avance de la pandemia hizo que las
bolsas se cerrarán en rojo en especial
madrid parís y londres para finalizar
que nos trae como cifra el día
los 2 731 millones de dólares a los que
correspondió el quinto premio de lotería
más grande de eeuu que cayó en una
humilde comunidad minera de maryland en
esta zona la tasa de pobreza del 22 por
ciento muy superior a la del país en
general muy afortunada así es la miel y
de esta manera entonces llegamos al
final de este bloque económico en france
24 muchísimas gracias a ustedes también
gracias continuo con nosotros buena
noche
[Música]